okay let's go over the the beginner
tesak for
katat um a couple rules are going to
play
here
is one is you need to
[Music]
have uh
qua me
foot
alignment okay that has to
stay uh as a golden rule don't break it
okay and in
Tachi your
qua is going
to connect with your elbow meaning
there's no there's no time ever where
the elbow and the claw are moving
independ ently of each other
okay
um this this is my understanding of what
Sheba used to try to get people to do he
would say elbow power the elbow power
comes from qua elbow alignment okay
so that's one rule and then the other
rule we have to
use
is the uh dividing up of the Torso so
this is like a human chest okay the head
is up
here uh we have the mid
line going straight down the
body okay and this is neither Yin nor y
now we have the outer shoulder line that
is
y and then you have the mid
chest on both sides
and that
is
Yin
okay and generally what you're going to
do is your elbow is the marker not not
your wrist per se
okay um your elbow's going to start on
yangong so that on the Yong line which
means your claw starts on the Y Line and
then it will move from the Yang line to
the yin line your elbow does okay and
that will put your your wrist somewhere
in somewhere in this
vicinity and that means their grip is
somewhere in this
vicinity
okay and only when your grab and your
wrist and their gra their grip whatever
is in this neither Yin or young line
that's where the other hand comes into
play and transitions okay at which point
your elbow on your other hands let's say
they're grabbing my right hand my right
elbow will move to the yin line my wrist
their grip is going to move to that
Center Line that's when the other hand
my left hand would come into play take
over and move my elbow from the yin line
back out to the Y Line and the same goes
for my CL okay at no point should we
ever be out here we're never out here
with our elbow and we're never fuzzy
either uh with this mid chest so if I
don't want to move my elbow to here it
was supposed to go to here I don't want
to move it to here because now my the
grab is somewhere around here and my
other hand which is taking over and
moving from yin yang is over uh Yin okay
so we'll keep those rules in mind as we
go forward and we'll do gon chudan and
jodon for katata DOI very very
basic okay so we already know how to
start in Han me and we already know he's
doing spinal displacement
okay and so get we already know too gon
is at the lower level but has this hand
shape the bottom portion of the outward
spiral
okay uh we know Chon has this shape it's
middle level but it's this shape and
then we also know that jodon is up here
on the top of the head and it has this
shape okay now we put it in
tabaki um there's something that I do
differently but I do it in all my keyho
and it's just not usually visible as
I've seen people go oh I like how you do
that let me try it and then they do this
other thing uh in terms of how how
they're understanding the relationship
to EDI ASI okay so
usually um there's no spinal
displacement on that guy he's just kind
of standing there or he's gripping
really hard in place trying to hold me
in which case there's no need for any
technique and then it's my job as Naga
to e e me and get myself to the back of
that person that's not viable that
doesn't work um and I have that XY
mentality where eventually you're going
to just be pushing or pulling in 180°
opposition so what I do instead is um
don't move I don't move yet I move him
okay and then as he's moving me if you
pay attention if you imagine looking
down he's going to look like he's going
around me okay I know it looks like he's
just on a diagonal like I'm going like
that but it's the beginning of of the
spiraling motion he's going this way
okay and so for
gon I bring the Palm up and in and now
you're going to see my elbow goes from
the Quad
line from the Yang line my qua moves and
the grip's now in the middle of my body
that's where I touch it okay and I
keep rotating an
in do it
again I don't move he moves qua moves
the
elbow to the in line elbow on the in
line grip is on the center line this
hand's waiting for
it and I enter
boom notice how I shift my weight back
there's your y yield the quad turns
boom this kind of Yono keeps the circle
going so it keeps turning and it's
making his hand do this okay
[Music]
when you come out of the
grip you pass through
Cheon so get on pass through chew down
to escape the
grip my
intering is again
more uh perpendicular to his angle of
attack okay I don't move up it so you'll
pay attention I'm going this way behind
him
never reach across yourself bring it to
your Center Line out you
go okay let's
try okay so you're moving the elbow
without your qua
moving where does your elbow go yeah in
the middle of your
chest turn your head
hips turn your
[Music]
hips
again turn the quaw that moves the elbow
good bring your grip to your middle
there you
go enter on the
turn that's
it all right so when you're working with
circles it's very important that you are
moving
what's going to feel like a head um so
that you can make the transitions
quickly
okay and fluidity with fluidity okay so
my hand is already here waiting to catch
that I don't want to leave my hand down
here and go like this and then I catch
it it's not going to work so my hand is
already moving to catch the grip the
wrist on my Center Line it already goes
to my Center Line you can see how I'm
doing that okay likewise and I don't
know where you have to move to get
this your Emi
cannot go like I'm going
there I'm going to put my foot right
there because as I enter this thing
keeps rotating you see and now I'm
pulling them
back you in the same way I don't know
what that's called in the ball sports
but you got to you got to lead whatever
you're doing you got to be ahead of
whatever you're doing uh so that you can
catch the ball with fluidity okay so my
H is already moving and when I enter I
enter on that Circle of where he's going
to be on that Circle in the time that it
takes me to get my foot on the completed
portion of Ed Mii okay so everything is
fluid fluid
fluid incorrect would be here I wait
then I go then I go past that you see
now I'm pulling them back towards me
[Music]
okay put it
together all right Cheon so again you
can't just go to Cheon so you have to
start with
gon and you do the same thing so that
qual moves the elbow comes into the yin
line and then the grips in the middle
your other hand is you're waiting for it
and this one goes over the
top in this cutting like fashion but
it's it going to be the same thing it
has to be the inward
spiral and the two hands inward spiral
together to get
out so again just showing the hard work
it's going to start and get
on the elbow goes from the Y Line with
the
qua to the
Y Line the grip's now on the middle of
my chest where the other hand is waiting
this does it inward spiral
here and they get out
Bo and then the ADI the same okay so
make sure same strategy bring him in
with your weight shifting your weight
shifts brings him in the other hand is
waiting keeps him going
and you injure on that
Circle boom
[Music]
you're here underneath don't come back
on top you're
underneath let's try go slow so we know
we move the qua moves the elbow good
Palm up Palm up
good touch at the mid line don't move
your right hand past your
midline there that all stays there okay
and now there we go Circle that's it and
again qua moves the elbow to the Y Line
the grip will come to the mid line good
don't move don't no no no don't move
that that left hand past your Center
Line leave it there okay go yep good
okay so your elbow your uh hand passes
the midline you're go
slower stay there this hand doesn't keep
going like that cuz now it passed okay
this hand's going to take over so go
back where you
were okay stay there see how you keep
wanting to pass it okay let's keep our
grip as we're training okay so watch
what happens to this
space right
here go back move her arm you see it
gets smaller okay and you can't get it
in there so but and then you also have
because we cross that midline this is
now only going to be reinforc per the
outer deltoid so as starts pushing in
you're going to you're outer deltoid so
you don't cross your midline it should
be off on that
hand get it in there there you
go just a a side note I again remember I
only have this these movements this is
all I have that's it your inward spiral
and your outward spiral or for our
pattern you only have the heart shape
that's that's all you do okay
so as I go here and I'm doing
uh get on you can see that that's the
beginning of your hour
spiral what's maybe is not so clear is
that this hand is going to do your
inward spiral but in Reverse so it's
going this way but because of the
rotation it comes around to the outside
as opposed to it okay but it's still the
same shape so I go in here and I'm going
to do the same
shape with working towards the
outside I'm
not going to go here and I pull this
that's not the shape okay I keep the
same movement
here as if you're going to come back for
a same thing goes on Che on so as you're
here like this it goes this way doing
the inward
spiral it doesn't go this way doing this
chop which we don't have okay this hand
again
continues with the award spiral to get
out hand go
go here this way to get
out but this hand does the same in
spiral in the same reverse way so I go
rotating
in keeps it going and keeps this shape
as it goes
[Music]
around here this way
this is
incorrect you are making shapes with
your uh body with your arms using your
elbows to govern what you're doing okay
so you shouldn't be here straight here
no this is where I was I have that shape
so I'm going to ask tayor do something
weird so you guys can understand what's
going on my my hand is in the naget
shape so if he stuck his head under
there get under there you see that's the
shape that I have okay all right all
right another note on uh Chon on The
Cutting hand so this hand right here all
right so uh you have to have the ike
adhesion skill to get that thing to
move otherwise you're going to want to
grab it otherwise you have no effect on
them they won't keep coming forward
you'll have to over prioritize his hand
so there's just there's just no way
around that that you wherever you're
touching so here I got some here here
I'm here and I have to match that keep
that going and as you go it keeps it
keeps going okay don't look for cuts or
hooks or all that kind of stuff it
doesn't really have to do it that long
but it does have to do it meaning I only
need it to go go to here now I have the
entry on the right angle and then the
other hand will assist the two can
assist and most people can that have any
I skills can definitely get it with two
hands if they can't get it one
okay all right Joon starts the same way
follows the same rules so I don't enter
I shift my weight back I turn my quad in
the elbow comes and I start with gon the
grip now is on the midline the other
hand is waiting for it in get gon and
again together the two hands will pass
through Chon and come
around and I do the same
entry so again wom waiting jodon starts
underneath okay Joon starts underneath
and then goes up
long keep
M and Jon you're on the outside don't be
on the top and don't be on the inside
you're on the outside so your adhesion
is out here on the
outside cover yourself
[Music]
likewise as you're doing this you're
going to have that same inward spiral
but it's being used going
outward don't go
here we don't have to do those straight
lines those won't teach me anything
okay all right try
it
stop
okay what hand
shape is this
one the inward spiral sensor what hand
shape gon Chon
jodon that's uh gon something yes but
what level are you Jon Jon so that can't
that we don't want that so let's go back
rewind the film okay so I can be at get
on level and as I start to climb up the
body the hand
rotates do you see yes so on the first
move stay there my elbow should be in to
the Y Line the half chest the grip then
is on the center line his G grip not
your hand you see so pay attention you
if I if you put your hand there and you
have the space you're supposed to have
in katatori do you get it if you put
your hand on your Center Line your elbow
is not on the mid chest so you put your
elbow there and now his grip is what you
want on the center line and it stays
there here's where this hand comes in in
gon and now as they go up they pass
through chudan and rotate into the knife
hand which is jodon keep
going okay got it all right so uh those
that those Hand Works is what you're
doing um energetically of course those
are the movement of L gong is moving in
that spiral rotation that starts the
lower Tom field uh spiral rotating that
this these movements don't do anything
these movements do not rotate anything
okay um so you're moving loud long and
and using that kind of mudra like aspect
uh to spiral rotate martially what
you're doing is you're learning how to
fight with your elbows inside your outer
rim my elbows never go outside my outer
rim and they're very pretty pretty tight
to my body the entire time okay um as
you're moving
these movements together you don't want
to think of them only for katatori um
nor do you want to think about them only
in hand transitions so for example uh
we've done uh uh Shaga right well as I
take part of one hand transition and
come around this way uh I just did the
gon on the same hand so in other words
here we got that and here's this do you
see
and I'm doing gon on the same hand on
that one we did that for example in the
sh it's right there
okay however that said we do have a
particular uh tactic that we did at the
end so we entered and we got to the back
and controlled the neck okay and what we
want to understand there is that it's
not so Universal I I understand it is
ultimately Universal and I have to
figure out how to use all these
different hand and elbow and forearm
shapes to do all of my pairing and all
my trapping and like you see in the C
you game okay but here I'm in the back
I'm controlling the arm and I'm
controlling the neck it's kind of
tactically specific so certain rules
come in um whenever you're on the
outside of the arm you have to be
above the
elbow you can't be below the elbow
because you're not controlling the hinge
and this thing can attack to the outside
that's kind of a general rule so if I'm
on the outside you're always above the
elbow never below the elbow if you're on
the inside it's the exact opposite you
want to be below the elbow not above the
elbow because you can't check the arm
weapon okay
so focusing in on that you're going to
see that it's solved in gon by I'm
holding it if you're holding it it's not
an issue you are controlling the elbow
in this case
okay it starts to become relevant in
Chon so as I go in here you're going to
see that I'm below the elbow no matter
how close I get I'm going to be below
the elbow if I obey all these rules but
once I start entering you'll see that on
the Emi and I turn I'm now above the
elbow okay don't be out here below the
elbow because you can't protect the
groin stripes and things like that
you're above the elbow so I'm doing uh
true do and you'll see that eventually I
get myself above the elbow as I'm just
going
sorry no this is incorrect I got to move
above the elbow
above the elbow okay where you check and
the same thing happens on jodon and
you're going to Jon you might start out
of
below generally tend to start out above
because it's it's much closer technique
and you just want to make sure that you
stay above and you don't go over here
and unanchor your elbow cuz you got the
same non check going on there so as I'm
going you'll see I move from here to
here which will happen
naturally if you
follow the elbow returns to the yog line
the only way you can not follow this
rule is you brought your elbow outside
that's the only way you can
reach that wrist so for example I keep
this here my elbow is in alignment with
my shoulder
and if I take it out that's the only way
you can reach that wrist okay and then
you unanchor your elbow and you can't
control his elbow You're
vulnerable so it goes back to follow our
rules okay this elbow here has to stay
with my shoulder can't go
out then you will break that Marshall
rule if you're on the outside contact is
above the elbow and let your riping the
wrist as Inon if you're on the inside
contact is below the elbow